we're also learning new details about
gunman Steven paddock and his arsenal
police say that paddock had 23 guns in
his hotel room located on the 32nd floor
of the Mandalay Bay Hotel 19 other
firearms found in his home that's a
total of 42 handguns Patek was also
known as a big gambler who had earned
money in real estate and investigators
say they want to talk to his girlfriend
Marilu Dan Lee when she returns from
Tokyo
they don't believe at this point that
she was involved CBS News contributor
Randi Sutton served in the Las Vegas
metropolitan Police Department for
almost 24 years he retired with the rank
of lieutenant good morning good morning
first of all the police first responders
did a fantastic job responding to this
have you spoken with any of your former
colleague yes I have they did indeed
just the bravery that was shown the the
great police work and the the fact the
matter is that had they not responded in
in the efficient manner and that they
did the body count would be even higher
and that's a startling conclude
you know that was one of the things that
happened once those gunfire began it was
finding where the shooter is how did
they do it well there was a couple
things first of all the officers that
were on the ground some off-duty some on
duty they they saw where the muzzle
flashes were coming from and they called
in they tried to isolate a bunch of
officers actually ran over to the hotel
and and went up they formed a team which
was it is how you respond to an active
shooter they made entry into the hotel
to get up to the area where they believe
that the that the gunfire was coming
from when they did find it they they
took fire from inside the room and then
they contacted SWAT because once once
they they took the gunfire they couldn't
get into the room so a dynamic entry had
to be done and the SWAT team which is
specially trained and has the equipment
and that's exactly what they did they
breach the door which means that they
they used an explosive device to enter
the room to get into access and and
confront the suspect but the suspect had
already killed him so when you're
talking about more than five hundred
wounded fifty-nine dead the types of
guns that he had they were modified
semi-automatic rifles is that what
you've heard yes this was one of the big
questions that that we had at the very
beginning of this were they fully
automatic weapons were they were they
manufactured as fully automatic weapons
word did he modify them and now
apparently the investigation has
revealed that these had been
semi-automatic weapons now what that
demonstrates to me is even a greater
intent that he purposefully had these
these weapons modified to be even
deadlier than
would be in there in the president
compiled in the capacity that they were
originally manufactured the difference
for your viewers who don't know the
difference between a semi-automatic and
a full automatic is that when the
semi-automatic every every time you you
depress the trigger one round comes out
when it's fully automatic when you press
the trigger it continues at a rate of
about 400 rounds per minute which is
which is why this death toll was so
incredibly high one other thing that a
question in my mind is how we got those
23 guns inside that hotel room heard
it's in big suitcases we're gonna look
for that surveillance video Randy Sutton
thank you so much we appreciate it